UNO Vollversammlung in New York
vielleicht noch wichtiger die vielen
vielen Treffen am Rande der Sitzungen
hat das die Ukraine dem Frieden in
irgendeiner Form ein Stück näher
gebracht
ja auch wenn es natürlich nicht bedeutet
dass morgen die Kampfhandlungen
eingestellt sind was furchtbar ist aber
diese Gespräche sind unglaublich wichtig
ich habe mit vielen Akteuren aus
unterschiedlichen Regionen der Welt
gesprochen die zum Beispiel nicht
wussten dass der russische Präsident
diesen Krieg nicht nur damit führt dass
er tagtäglich Dörfer Städte Schulen
Krankenhäuser bombardiert mit Drohnen
angreift sondern zum Beispiel auch
Kinder systematisch entführt aus der
Ukraine rund 20.000 Kinder sollen
verschleppt worden sein und das mit
unterschiedlichen Vertretern aus anderen
Ländern nicht nur zu besprechen sondern
ihn deutlich zu machen dass das
allerwichtigste ist dass diese Kinder
zurückkommen das sind zum Beispiel
Beiträge die hier geleistet werden
können wo dann auch Länder die sich
bisher nicht klar positioniert haben
sagen okay das ist vollkommen klar das
ist ein absolutes Kriegsverbrechen und
wir müssen unsere Stimme erheben
apropositionieren in der UN gibt es ja
das Problem bzw im Sicherheitsrat
Russland liegt immer ein vetor ein
ukraines Präsident zielenski hat gestern
darüber geklagt wie machtlos die UNO sei
Stichwort eben Reform sie beklagen das
ja auch wie kann es denn gelingen dass
die Staatengemeinschaft stärker im Sinne
von Betroffenen wie der Ukraine handelt
indem wir unsere Kräfte bündeln und uns
nicht damit klein beigeben dass der
Sicherheitsrat blockiert ist das ist
leider der Fall wir können die Statuten
der UN nicht von heute auf morgen ändern
und deswegen
genau deswegen haben wir vor anderthalb
Jahren gemeinsame Initiative ergriffen
in der Generalversammlung wo alle
Staaten der Welt zusammenkommen wo jeder
Staat zählt und über 140 Länder auf der
Welt haben dann klar und deutlich gesagt
wir verurteilen diesen brutalen
russischen Angriffskrieg und zugleich
müssen wir an Reformen der UN arbeiten
dafür wirkt Deutschland seit langem dass
der Sicherheitsrat erweitert wird Länder
aus Afrika sind ja bisher überhaupt
nicht vertreten Lateinamerika auch nicht
und diesen Prozess den müssen wir
zweigleisig angehen aber wir können auf
diese Reform natürlich nicht warten weil
die Menschen in der Ukraine die sterben
tagtäglich nun äh gibt es Länder die
spielen eine gewichtige Rolle weil sie
na ja so hin und her pendeln sie
verurteilen den Krieg nicht auf ganzer
Linie aber setzen sich trotzdem für den
Frieden ein Stichwort Staaten es gibt ja
ein Treffen auch mit Brasilien mit
Indien eben sehr sehr wichtige Staaten
die Einfluss ausüben können wie weit
sind sie da
diplomatie ist kein einfaches Geschäft
erst recht nicht wenn ein so machtvolles
Land wie Russland mit jeglichen Regeln
auf dieser Welt bricht und wir haben
gesehen dass es sich dennoch lohnt jeden
Tag für den Frieden zu streiten am
Anfang genau wie Sie gesagt haben haben
sich Länder wie Brasilien überhaupt
nicht positioniert Länder wie Südafrika
haben sogar in internationalen Gremien
gesagt naja vielleicht war nicht selber
die Ukraine schuld weil sie in die NATO
wollte das hat sich komplett verändert
weil wir Tag und Nacht dafür geworben
haben genau hinzuschauen zu sehen wer es
hier der Angreifer und wer ist hier das
Opfer Themen wie die Verschleppung von
Kindern thematisiert haben deutlich
gemacht haben dass ein Angriff auf Strom
Versorgung Wasserversorgung
Wärmeversorgung im Winter
Kriegsverbrechen sind und da hat sich in
den letzten anderthalb Jahren was
verändert afrikanische Staaten sind nach
Kiew gereist waren in Botschaft wo die
schlimmsten gerollt hatten stattgefunden
haben und haben gegenüber dem russischen
Präsidenten das bei ihrem Besuch dann in
petersburg angesprochen wie gesagt das
sind kleine Schritte aber jeder Schritt
Richtung Frieden der lohnt Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat sich gestern auch mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten getroffen hat
sich da glaube ich eine halbe Stunde
unterhalten und selensky hat darauf
gepocht dass Deutschland
seinem Land Taurus marschflug Körper
liefert es gibt ja heute auch ein
Treffen zwischen dem ukrainischen und
dem US-Präsidenten und daran ist das ja
glaube ich auch gekoppelt wie weit ist
man da wann wird Deutschland Taurus
Marschflugkörper liefern
sowohl der Bundeskanzler als auch ich
haben ja in den letzten Tagen immer
wieder deutlich gemacht dass uns klar
ist dass es Möglichkeiten geben muss die
Menschen in der Ostukraine endlich zu
befreien da ist ein riesiger minengürtel
der überwunden werden muss und zwar der
ist zum Teil hunderte Kilometer breit
und wir prüfen daher wie wir das mit
unterstützen können ich war ja bevor ich
hier in die USA gereist bin gerade auch
selber erst in kieft deswegen weiß ich
wie dringend diese Frage ist aber ich
kann jetzt natürlich Gespräche zwischen
dem amerikanischen Präsidenten und dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten nicht vorweg
greifen aber wenn sich die USA heute
entscheiden sollten oder morgen der
Ukraine Raketen zu liefern ist es
wahrscheinlicher dass Deutschland dann
auch die Taurus Flughafen liefert
wir haben ja
unglaublich viele unterschiedliche
Waffensysteme bereits geliefert
hochmoderne iristesysteme wir sind nach
den USA die stärksten Unterstützer diese
Taurus Systeme um die es jetzt geht das
ist hoch spezielles technologisches
Gerät deswegen müssen wir das für uns
auch sehr genau prüfen wie das zum
Einsatz kommen kann und wie gesagt in
Erklärung dieser Fragen sind wir
mittendrin vielen Dank für das Gespräch
Grüße nach New York das war die
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
Dankeschön schönen Tag noch es ist sein
erster Auftritt beim UN-Sicherheitsrat
seit dem russischen Einmarsch in sein
Land wie gewohnt in olivgrüner Uniform
direkt gegenüber sitzt Russlands
Botschafter bei den Vereinten Nationen
es folgt der versuchte lenskis Rede zu
verhindern allerdings vergeblich der
Vorsitzende des Gremiums entgegnet
Russland kühl stoppen sie den Krieg dann
wird Präsident selenski nicht das Wort
ergreifen
silensky spricht beklagt die
Machtlosigkeit der Vereinten Nationen
wie kann es sein dass ein Aggressor ein
Vetorecht hat er fordert Reformen nur
wenige Meter entfernt der russische
Botschafter der sich an sein Handy
klammert um den Schafen blicken und
Worten zu entgehen
mit einer zwei drittelmehrheit die die
internationale Gemeinschaft
widerspiegelt mit Asien Afrika Europa
Nord und Südamerika und der Pazifik
Region mit dieser qualifizierten
Mehrheit sollte das Veto überstimmt
werden können
Wunsch und Wirklichkeit eine
aussichtslose Forderung erst als
silensky das wichtigste Gremium verlässt
betritt Russlands Außenminister den Saal
keine direkte Konfrontation wie gewohnt
macht er den Westen verantwortlich für
den Krieg in der Rhetorik unserer
westlichen Gegner hören wir Invasion
Aggression und Annektion aber nichts
über die Ursachen des Problems russland
hat sich von der Weltordnung entfernt
die üblichen diplomatischen
Geflogenheiten sind längst passiert
Bundeskanzler Scholz reagiert mit einer
scharfen Republik
the reason der Grund dafür dass das Leid
in der Ukraine und überall auf der Welt
andauert ist erschütternd einfach
russlands Präsident will seinen
imperialistischen Plan umsetzen und sein
souverän Nachbarn die Ukraine erobern
silensky Werte den Krieg gegen sein Land
als Angriff auf die gesamte Welt jeder
könnte das nächste Opfer sein von New
York reiste er nach Washington um sich
der Unterstützung des wichtigsten
Verbündeten zu vergewissern